[Music]
all I have for you is a word
[Music]
it'll open the right doors some of the
wrong ones to use it carefully to do
what I do I need some idea of the threat
we face as I understand it we're trying
to prevent World War 3 I'm not saying
I'm again something was I can't do you
have an interest in a certain national
like spring man
you can communicate with the future
tap trouble no inversion a mitten in
poetry you know shooting the bullet you
know catching it
what I've seen too much my work try and
Cooper
community transcends national interests
this is about survival
seems whoa hold up find that I were
gonna say nuts
where
how would you like to die oh you chose
the wrong profession
[Music]
I know that some here has it happened
yet
there are people in the future when he
does
I'm a tenant
we need to save them here and now
this reversing the flow of time wasn't
us being here now it never happened
[Music]
you want to crash a plane but not from
the air no such visor well having a
plane that part is a little dramatic we
all believe we've run into the burning
building but until we feel that heat
we can never know
you do you chose to tie instead of
giving up your colleagues
[Music]
about test you passed
not everybody does
welcome to the afterlife
[Music]
to do what I do I need some idea of the
threatening face as I understand it
we're trying to prevent World War 3
nuclear holocaust
something was
all I have for you is the word tenant it
will open the right doors
some of the wrong ones too
I have to start looking at the weather
in a new way
don't try to understand it feel it has
it happened yet
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]